I feel too bad what I'm doing to him
we're at day three back checking in back
in the fight and I'm started to up my
battle a little bit and I started to do
something in my parent my brother said
to me that I hated
I put vaseline and basically every
pocket that he had jacket pocket pant
pocket anything oh that will drive you
slowly crazy right and I could hear him
gonna bite you and that is funny because
my wife calls me into the bedroom she
cuz you come in here I got short and I
look on the mirror in written in
Vaseline on the mirror I can't wait to
fight you and she goes you happy with
yourself and I go yeah actually I'm
pretty habit I go you just wrote a death
wish Sweden Vaseline he's ready to snap
like he's I'm not gonna have to wait 12
days he's ready to go right now right
and by the way I don't want any what
they feeling bad for them but things
that I do to them they get me just as
much do you understand that like that's
part of the thing in our family like
funny is funny funny wins and they skate
I scare really easily and my daughter
scared me because I also smoke a lot of
weed and uh and so my daughter scared me
one time she hit in the front yard so
they know that I come home high every
now and then and she was waiting in the
front yard in a long white flowy gown
and a scream man I walked into the yard
and she was like and I jazz hands when I
gets got I make a lap when I jazz hand
there's like a million videos they have
of me going like this so [ __ ] them they
get everything they got everything
but I knew my son was getting ready to
lose his mind right so I started to step
up my game and I did something to him
that my brothers did to me that used to
drive me crazy they used to put Tabasco
sauce on my fingertips when I was
sleeping well because the first thing
you do when you wake up in the morning
is what you go pee anybody who's ever
touched a jalapeno and then go to the
bathroom yeah that's not fun you know
so I put the bashful sauce in his
fingertips and I just wait I wait five
in the morning I get up I sit in the
living room and I hear him go to the
bathroom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey is it Hank Neos what does it mean
what what does it mean if your penis is
on fire
[Applause]
say well it could mean a lot of things
oh yeah like what like what like what
and said well you could have a virus and
wanted to do that appeal the lawyers
what do you do I'm 11 they take a needle
you stick it in the base of your penis
what be the shot I don't want one of
those what else what else what other was
there any other option I go well yeah I
said with it you could have like a
bacterial infection oh okay what is that
what does that mean how do they fix up I
go well they take a needle and then
stick it in the base you oh another shot
well I don't want to is there any option
besides penis shot I left my own I go
with this and one the third one but it's
so rare like it never happens you think
what is it I'm like it just doesn't
happen because what is it is the de
Peter shouting oh no he was told me
would I go okay go it's possible but
never happens but it's possible somebody
snuck into your room and put Tabasco
sauce on your
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and he was like I'm gonna fight you so
I'm like don't say that don't say that
sound like listen right now we're at the
house we're at day 5 and he's ready to
snap after the Vaseline I know he's
ready to snap so I do the thing to him
that my brothers did to me that made me
snap the quickest they used to lock me
in my bathroom oh yeah for hours now I
wasn't gonna lock him in for hours just
like an hour and a half oh my god
and so when he's in the bathroom I take
some rope and I tie it to the handle and
tie the other part of the rope to the
doorbell tore the door other door handle
and I just sitting I wait and I hear the
toilet flush and then I just hear the
door handle and I get a text unblocked
in the bathroom
so I sent him a text back I know and
then it was just like in a horror movie
all from the inside of the bathroom all
I heard is are you out there
and I said you know I am he goes you let
me out of here right now break the door
down
and I pick up my phone I'm like break it
down there's anyone in here ever seen
someone try to break down the door some
funny [ __ ] the first time I saw it I was
in college and my buddy was like I'm
being a [ __ ] out of this guy I go let's
go
and he goes to his house the door was
locked and he was like I'm breaking it I
go break it and my buddy went in his
liquid because it's a [ __ ] door
everybody that's why they put it up
there so you can't walk in and out all
really Nick if you think you can break
down a door you watch too much long
order that's all I'm saying
the door so your girls I'm gonna break
it down and the reason I have my camera
up guys it's cuz I'm gonna film it
because I already have my wife and I
have a video that's seven and a half
minutes long of dumb [ __ ] that he's done
that we're gonna play at his wedding
so I'm like this is gonna be a perfect
perfect video now guys I have on that
video 90 seconds of the best thing
you've ever seen in your life
funnier than anything you ever seen on
YouTube funnier than anything you've
ever seen in a movie TV show anything my
son such an excitable just loving life
person even as a young young young young
young boy he rushed through [ __ ] so I
have 90 seconds of a video because we
were playing in the living room and he
went to the bathroom and when he ran out
he was not careful in the bathroom and
he had a little bit of [ __ ] on his
earlobe I have a 90 second video of him
doing this hey you want to play what is
that
[Applause]
you guys saw five seconds of it I have
85 four seconds of desert it's the best
thing I've ever seen in my life whenever
I'm in a bad mood I'm like throwing the
tape like that is the best thing I've
ever seen so I have it up like this
right
I'm ready cuz I know what's gonna happen
he goes I'm breaking it down I go do it
and he goes one two three and all I hear
is ooh silence
it's quiet for like two three minutes
and then that he comes he goes I'm
pretty sure this is child abuse
[Applause]
and I said yeah which part he was like
dig all of it silence for like another
three minutes ladies hit something maybe
laugh so hard I to leave the room I just
hear from the bathroom I'm hungry
oh it's like come back in the room and
this is what I do he start to crack he
goes dad dad listen listen if you crack
the door and slip in a sandwich I
promise not to try to get out I'm like a
[ __ ] Stockholm Syndrome is Satan
anyway this day ago she ate with his
captors and stuff you know I go I can't
do that man he's like oh this is one I
knew he was ready to fight I just heard
him starting to mumble to himself oh and
then he said this he goes no when I get
out of here I'm just gonna shake him and
I was like [ __ ] I've never been so mad
round like I was like oh he's ready to
fight I know you ready to come out man
he goes your brother and I go okay and I
open the door you've never seen a bull
come out of a shoot at a rodeo or all
their muscles are moving at once and he
come out he's like I'm gonna bite you so
hard
are you ready cuz I'm ready I go let's
go he's not yet I gotta change into my
bike clothes I'm like that so I got on
the hallway and I see my wife Beth and
she's like listen you sure you still
want to fight him I go he just he was
just talking much shaking somebody so
he's gonna fight somebody today so might
as well be me she said this is nothing
good is gonna come out of this nothing
good even if you win nothing good comes
out of this she said I really think it's
a bad idea and I said what did I tell
you about that I'll let you know when I
have a bad idea
and she was like okay and I go just do
me a favor just put my phone in the
window cuz when I pin him that's gonna
be the end of the wedding video like
that's a good way to go out wedding
video over me pinning him right she goes
okay
[Music]
[Music]